well just coming out of that to bring
you some
breaking news in the uh political
sphere uh rob powell can join us at
westminster and if people weren't
confused by
boris johnson and the chancellor rishi
sunak being
pinged and isolating or not isolating
another twist rob yeah a full u-turn
from
number 10 for the prime minister and the
chancellor a statement from a number 10
spokes
man in the last few minutes saying that
after the prime minister was contacted
by nhs test and tray saying he'd been in
contact with someone who had coveted
um he will now be isolating he won't be
taking part
in that pilot that daily testing pilot
that allows uh
people to get out of isolation if they
do a test every day
the chancellor as well rishi sunak whose
tweet you can see there on the screen
will also not be taking part um in that
pilot he's tweeted saying whilst the
test and trace pilot is fairly
restrictive
allowing only essential government
business i recognize that even the sense
that the rules aren't the same for
everyone
is wrong to that end i'll be
self-isolating as normal
and not taking part um in the pilot
now the number 10 spokesman says that
when boris johnson was informed
uh that he had been in contact with
someone that had tested positive with
uh covert the health secretary sachit
javid who tested positive yesterday
uh he was um at checkers which is his
countryside
residence just outside london in
buckinghamshire the spokesman says
that he will remain there to isolate
he won't be taking part in the testing
pilot and he will continue to conduct
meetings with ministers remotely so
in the space of uh what two hours and 42
minutes we have
a full u-turn on that decision for both
senior
politicians to take part in that pilot i
think that this will have been driven
in part by the pretty obvious sense that
this gave out to the millions of people
that are having to self-isolate
and are not able to go into work uh that
it was one rule for people at the top of
government and another rule for others
you